Suma y sigue, señores del gobierno del partido popular,
suma y sigue. Nos hablan y nos hablarán
seguramente en la en la respuesta,
en la réplica de colaboración público privada,
pero nosotros les decimos que si suena a privatización,
si huele a privatización,
si se tramita como si fuera 1 privatización,
lo más probable
es que estemos hablando de privatizaciones.
Atrévanse a llamar a las cosas
por su nombre y a defender su modelo privatizador,
si es que creen que es lo más oportuno.
Desde luego nosotros eh nos vamos a enfrentar
permanentemente a que el dinero de los riojanos
y de las riojanas,
el dinero público,
se dedique a engrosar
los beneficios de entidades privadas